joining us now for the full hour the
45th president of the United States
Donald Trump Mr President good to see
you that was a very good job okay okay
so I've done that before I have once in
a while but a number of years thank you
very much so your whole family you saw
the Leticia James Professor terrible
okay
what was your reaction well she
campaigned on it four years ago was a
vicious campaign and she just talked
about Trump and we're going to indict
him we're going to get him she knew
nothing about me I never heard of her
but I saw this woman I saw the statement
she was putting out without knowing
anything and she said we're going to get
him that her whole campaign was based on
that and then she came after us we've
been going over this for years and I
actually thought because our values are
really high the company is great I built
a great company you take places like
this so many other places that I have
like this frankly I mean just the among
the finest places anywhere in the world
I actually thought that they would never
bring a case and she brought it and the
reason I thought because she didn't have
a case I was of the impression she
wanted to settle but I had a problem
because how do you pay something even if
it's a small amount of money if you're
not guilty this was just a continuation
of a Witch Hunt that began when I came
down the escalator at Trump Tower with
or who would know our great future first
lady who's done a great job and people
love her but we came down the escalator
and it started but I'm so proud of what
we did with the strongest Border in the
country we had the biggest tax cuts and
regulation Cuts we had the best
employment ever in the country we're
energy independent we did things that
nobody ever thought possible we would
have been energy dominant throughout the
world in a very short period of time
much larger than Russia much larger than
Saudi Arabia put together we were all
set and then they came along and they
just dismantled that they wouldn't
finish the wall the wall was completed
the original section was completed I
said let's do more we did more he could
have had that finished in three weeks
and now you have millions and millions
of people pouring through we had the
strongest Border in history and by the
way that included drugs too we had drugs
down 19 from what they were the previous
year and 20 percent from what they were
that previous year we were doing great
and now the drugs are pouring into our
country at level that nobody's seen and
the people they're emptying out their
prisons
let me go back to Leticia James did you
ever in your life fill out a loan
application running the Trump
organization
well you know we make loans but I have
very little debt you know here's what I
want to tell you I might I might add one
thing they've demeaned me for years with
this stuff and now they find out I have
very little debt very very little a lot
of cash we have a great company and we
have among the best assets anywhere in
the world but I went through they were
demeaning me you know constantly these
people there's something wrong with them
I think I really believe they hate our
country I was told that in your
financial statements when you make a
loan application and you can confirm if
you know this or not know this do you
put in a caveat that actually says these
are our valuations yeah because I don't
know a lending institution a bank a
financial institution that would lend
money to anybody and just go by the
borrower's estimation evaluation of a
particular property so if you're buying
a 100 million dollar property and you're
putting X Y and Z up for leverage you
estimate its value of this they
estimated at this don't they have a
fiduciary responsibility before you they
give you that amount of money so what
they determine what the value is
especially with these are banks that
have the best law firms in the world the
biggest and best and most powerful they
do their own work they don't rely on us
but what they do is we have a disclaimer
and we put together my people put it
together I would look at it and it
looked fine but it's not overly
important what's important is the
property I have the best property what
happened Sean is we have a disclaimer
right on the front and it basically says
you know get your own people you're at
your own risk this was done by
management it wasn't done by it was done
by management so don't rely on the
statement that you're getting and it's
and by the way it goes on for like a
page and a half it's a very big
disclaimer it's a very powerful
disclaimer it basically says to an
institution you're going to loan money
you have to go out and make sure that
you know you get your own appraisers
your own lawyers everything
These Are banks that have the best
lawyers in the world Sean
this is the only Case by the way that
got paid back just so you know nobody
got I never got a default no I paid them
back because we have a lot of cash I
paid them back I paid many of them off I
have very little debt unbelievably
little bit of the loans off so here's so
there was no harm no no bank they didn't
lose money so you told every institution
what you believe the valuation is they
have a fiduciary responsibility before
they give you 100 or 200 or 300 million
dollars to buy a property they have that
responsibility to come up with their own
valuation because they've got their own
bosses and shareholders that they have
to answer to so they would look at a
property like this I don't even have a
mortgage on this property I don't have a
mortgage on most of my properties you
know I used to read where I was
overextended and he had so much money to
borrow it and I'm saying what are they
talking about but and actually the one
good thing is people see what a great
company I built I built a great company
a powerful company a company that's very
lowly leveraged with the among the best
assets anywhere in the world I mean you
look at this asset she has this down to
75 million dollars I can tell you it's
many times that number she said oh he
valued it at 75 or whatever it was or
she valued at 75. what is Leticia James
know but if I were going I don't have a
mortgage on this property if I was going
to put a mortgage on this property the
institutions are going to be coming over
they're going to go through comparable
properties all over Palm Beach or
whatever it is wherever it may be Miami
we have them all over we have tremendous
properties and again we have very little
debt
the debt we did have it was it was paid
current the banks made a lot of money
she's trying to defend banks that got
paid off she's trying to defend
banks that had unbelievable legal talent
I will tell you that they're very good
you don't there's no loan that you can
think of where they didn't do their own
valuation their own vetting their own
Financial assessment all right by the
way they have people in
that do it too right but you can't just
say you know here's a financial step but
what we do is here's a financial
statement but be careful because it may
not be accurate it may be way off I mean
we go it's I think it's close to a page
and a half of all of these things get
your own people use your own appraisers
use your own lawyers don't rely on us
and then she sued us now again I didn't
think this would ever happen because
they had no case I met with them I
actually thought they wanted to settle
but I didn't want to settle because how
can you even if I paid a very small
amount you sort of admitting guilt that
she offer you a settlement deal I could
have said my opinion I could have
settled the case hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else